weather right yeah yes weather is great
great 88 degrees on dad's day i mean for
june yeah this whole month has been
fairly mild
about it
and can we keep that trend going so
let's see look live look outside right
now strat cam looking towards the south
yes we're also tracking signs of the
monsoon now you're probably saying hey
we usually get that in july where you're
right now we're starting to see early
signs of it making its way up towards us
live look outside there almanac the high
for the day today get this 99 degrees so
bye bye that 88 we had for dad's day
this puts us just a couple digits below
our average nowhere near that record of
114. last year we were 108.71 for your
morning start not bad at all the
mornings in june have been pretty pretty
good 98 in centennial hills right now 96
for you in sky canyon double nines still
hot for you north las vegas downtown
included 101 for whitney ranch green
valley mountains edge 96 spanish trail 2
in southern highlands you're 97 how
about henderson right now coming in and
checking it at 101 degrees 110 and hot
out in death valley 104 for your loft in
boulder city you're checking in at 98
degrees so here's our satellite radar
typically we see the monsoon returned
for areas like arizona and new mexico
we've been seeing them lately now we
started to see it move up a little more
through havasu and then die out fizzle
out before it reached june kingman that
could change though tomorrow in fact for
our region here
we're going to up the chances for storms
for wednesday and thursday slight
chances but the possibilities out there
for isolated storms not so much as we
get in the weekend those numbers start
to drop a little more so tonight we'll
see increased clouds for us 79 degrees
your morning start that's going to be a
warm start your high tomorrow 96 so
actually cooler tomorrow but we'll have
cloud cover and the chances for
thunderstorms could be gusty at times
because what happens is if it's so dry
in the surface the rain evaporates we
call that virgo and it sends gusts of
wind and even outflow winds from nearby
storms so we'll keep a little gusty at
times
for tomorrow your eight day forecast
there's those chances for thursday as we
get to the weekend we get hotter as we
dry out we get hotter 105 for sunday
that'll be the hottest day this eight
day forecast next week slight chances
again of the monsoon
returning for
next week coming up we'll talk about
what we could see could see more
lightning can we see more gusts of wind
can we see any rainfall i got all that
all for you i'll break it down for you
coming up all that info is ahead that's
all ahead all answers
look at sports what's